all right um more importantly and and
look how you play in the uniforms is
going to influence dramatically whether
the uniforms look good or not good if
the rams are like they were a couple of
years ago all of a sudden those uniforms
are going to look pretty good to rams
fans who's got the brighter future in
their new uniforms jared goff with the
rams or justin herbert with the chargers
well yeah i mean jared goff of course
has had a very good start to his career
um as you know mike i i've never been a
just an absolute blown away huge fan by
jared goff's talent justin herbert to me
has superstar potential you know again
he's got to get in the nfl and play and
you know they got to support him the
right way just like the rams supported
jared goff but i think ultimately hey in
my draft process this year you heard me
say it i'm not so sure herbert doesn't
have the most potential or the highest
ceiling at any of the quarterbacks that
were drafted we'll see how it goes but
when you're that big and your arm's that
strong and you can run that way you got
a chance to be a really really special
player in the nfl
who's got the better coaching staff
between the two teams chris who's
because look we just said no brainer
sean mcvay a year ago but
you know as you've said they're catching
up with the sean mcvay offense which
teams got the better top to bottom staff
yeah it's it's close it really is you
know and and you know with wade phillips
not being with the rams anymore i think
that you know even closes the gap a
little bit more but i'm still going to
go with the rams there i am you know and
and sean mcveigh kind of being the tie
breaker one i think sean mcveigh like we
talked about is going to reinvent
himself i think that's probably a big
reason we didn't see their staff at the
combine and things like that because
they were going to stay back there and
experiment and start putting new things
and and have new wrinkles within their
offense
so you know both rock both coaching
staff's pretty damn good but i'm going
to give the rams the edge
right now because of mcveigh the
offensive line coach joe berry who i
know there uh you know and of course
their success recently
all right who's got the better chance of
leading their division come november the
rams in the division that has the 49ers
or the chargers in the division that has
the chiefs
wow i i mean i
i don't even know where to go there you
know i guess i'm going to take the rams
there just because i don't think the
chargers are going to be able to
supplant the chiefs right now and as
much as the nfc west is amazing i mean
what do you think i just i you know the
nfc west is amazing i'm still not
counting the rams out i still look at
the roster and mcbay and everything and
go they they could be a pain in the butt
in the nfc west
i think it's the rams just because of
the chiefs if the rams were in the afc
west and the charges were in the nfc
west i'd say the chargers i just think
the chiefs are going to continue to
dominate that division regardless of who
else is in it and yeah it's not going to
be easy for the rams and they may end up
in the basement this year i think they
have to worry about the cardinals
catching them look the worst thing that
could have happened to sean mcvay was to
be so good so early and so young as a
coach because now reality sets in and
when you set for yourself a bar that all
of a sudden you can't match people start
wondering what the hell happened to sean
mcvay and you're not being compared to
other coaches you're being compared to
yourself from two years ago that's a
tough one for mcvey to process and he's
gonna have to as you said reinvent
himself in order to get back to where we
perceived him to be a couple of years
ago all right here's a good one would
you rather coach a defense in la with
aaron donald
on
your front line or would you rather have
the other la defense with joey bosa on
the edge and derwin james on the last
line of defense oh man
that is i mean so are we just counting
those two players are we taking like the
whole justice seven just two players
okay i'm going to take care of that
all right yeah i'm going to take care
and because you know joey bosa and
german james who we both know are
amazing aaron donald
is like on i mean he's he's right now
looking like he's going to be in the
conversation for one of the greatest
defensive players to ever play in the
history of the nfl i mean so to me
that's just special you know it really
is i mean he's you know
warren sapp lawrence taylor whatever you
want to talk about difference making
front seven type players aaron donald
like we've seen so many players talk
about him he changes the way teams have
to play the rams because he's such a
special talent
all those teams that passed on aaron
donald than 24. what do you say are you
going donald too
i'll take donald i'll take donald
because look joey bose has been banged
up from time to time in his career and
darwin james was injured last year and
we've yet to see his full potential i'd
rather go all eggs in the aaron donald
basket because you're right he's one of
the all-time greats and look of all the
bad decisions the rams have made in
recent years and they've made plenty of
them especially when it comes to giving
out contracts the aaron donald deal is
the one that they got right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports